[Music]
so we're partners co-workers not
necessarily a team not
[Music]
we look damn good though
hi malcolm how are you how you doing
abida
i'm doing good um congratulations by the
way and the release of falcon animated
soldier i think we're all really really
excited to see it thank you
now um i know that this is your first
run at marvel how do you react when you
found out that you were officially
appointed to write and run falcon in the
winter soldier it was huge it was a it
was a i mean it's a thing
that i grew up with the books
and i knew i wanted to take a shot at
trying to be involved with uh the marvel
universe and you know i was really
strategic about when i raised my hand
uh and i competed hard and i i can't
tell you it was like an out-of-body
experience
the first day up there on marvel's
second floor
congratulations i mean i think i watched
the first episode and i think it's
incredibly amazing um and i know that it
takes place um after the events of
endgame
so what's one story element from end
game that you want to tackle in the
series
um well the whole world end game
is very alive in our series because
once
thanos is
dispatched
and 3.5 billion people's give or take
reappear after five years it sends the
world into chaos
and we knew
that a world in chaos felt very much
like the world today particularly
dealing with this global pandemic
um so you know we that was the that was
the governing principle from where all
the stories came from
okay
um now i i know that it's gonna be a
really action-packed series just based
on the trailer itself so from one to end
game end game being like the most action
pack how would you rate the series
um i think you saw the first episode
right i did i did we we were very
judicious meaning this we never we don't
let our foot off the gas
at the same time
this series spends really spends a lot
of time with these characters and it
does it in a way
that
the time you spend with the characters
also manifests and progresses
through uh uh the action moments but we
didn't set up to like the action happens
organically and it is action-packed for
sure
but we wasn't showing up with that
agenda we was let we just let the story
unfold naturally um um if that makes
sense
totally it's totally done now i think
just action aside i know that the falcon
arena soldier is set to take a deeper
look at black manhood in america sorry
how would this series delve into this
it's it's right there at the surface
like you see it immediately in that
first episode and it goes deeper and
deeper and deeper
sam being a black man
can't in good conscious
just
accept that symbol without
serious consideration to both sides
of whether it's appropriate for him to
uh
to don it and
we wanted that argument
about not
doing it to be legitimate you know i'm
saying we wanted it we because that's
that's real if you're going to tell an
honest story right it's not even about
politics
it is you can't write a character who's
a woman you write can't write a
character who's
muslim or catholic or jewish
and just ignore that right sam is a
black man
and that is going to be at the forefront
with those stars and stripes and like i
said it just gets more and more intense
as the series continues and it does not
end in an obvious place as you already
know from what you saw yeah
now i know with the heartbreaking
passing of chadwick boseman many
children especially black children
now have one last superhero that
reflects them on screen
did you feel any sort of responsibility
when writing the character of sam for
this series absolutely my nephew
kingston wears his black panther costume
all the time you know what i'm saying
these icons are crucial for the world to
see
and um i felt a tremendous
responsibility
in doing this and i know anthony did too
and you know we made sure we or we hope
we got it right and it was definitely
our greatest intention to be
uh uh really thoughtful about it and not
just be frivolous or superficial
yeah i think just adding on to that you
know i've done a lot of research about
you and i know you did empire i think a
lot of my friends and i love empire
and
a lot of their stories actually focus on
the black experience um
why do you think it's important to
explore and celebrate black stories
through different lenses and
perspectives
i would say one of the crucial things is
we are preeminent in pop culture it's
sports music
entertainment in general
because our story
is
the core of american
and the american story is the big loud
story in the world still to this day
and our experience is a concentrated
version
for our struggles and our triumphs that
people of all races can relate to
because ours is so intense
um and so i just think it's there's
something
it's it's gonna be uplifting and good
for people
to hear us have a voice because you're
gonna hear something you you very human
in anything we do that you'll be able to
relate to no matter what race or
religion you are
thank you
um just out of curiosity um we haven't
really seen anthony mackie or like sam
and sebastian kind of worked together in
this series yet um they appear
separately in the first episode but just
out of curiosity do do they like often
bicker and go hit a hit in real life on
set or is that just great acting and
writing on your part
it's natural for them seriously that
that energy you see
none of us can take credit for them that
is 100 them and it's 100 real
all right i think that's all the time i
have today thank you so much